I'm not the most dangerous YouTuber I'm
like who is the most dangerous the most
dangerous I could probably so there's a
rock okay so here's the thing when we do
stuff
are always aware of the wrist yeah and
like we're not going to put ourselves in
a situation where we're like knowingly
doing something really bad yeah and a
lot of times people will see something
that is dangerous yeah and then that's
like immediate Panic where it's like oh
there's high voltage or oh there's this
that's dangerous that's dangerous and
it's like you know what like if how do
you think they made helicopters yeah
you think they just built a helicopter
and it worked the first time
I was like I thought you were alluding
to some like horrible helicopter-based
accident I [ __ ] you not there's this um
horrible amazing video of like the guy
who's like piloting one of the first
helicopters it's like vibrating and it
like bounces and the rotor kicks them
and like launches him and he's like
totally fine that's what they said at
least
he's paralyzed apparently he kept flying
it maybe yeah I I could be wrong but I
remember it I'm not an Xbox
video I'm pretty sure there are some
videos I see on the inside like some of
the compilations of like near-death
compilations on YouTube and then like
disclaimer all these people are fired
and I'm like can I get a source for that
I see some of these Cliffs and they
definitely don't [ __ ] look have you
heard of the Ford Pinto no no like one
of the big issues with you know car
manufacturing back in the day I think
it's like the 70s or 60s right when they
get rear-ended the doors would jam so it
would compress the frame oh yeah they
crumple now right yeah and so you
couldn't open the doors and then they
would also like catch on fire all right
and so the decision was to pay out the
claims as opposed to fix the design flaw
that to me is a huge No-No when it comes
to Danger like I'm not going to put
other people's lives yeah right unless
they understand what we're doing okay
that makes sense so
myself I'm willing to put you know like
Kevin the backyard scientist Nigel
get them in danger but also at the same
time they are well aware of what the
danger is yeah yeah I mean they're
Educators on the stuff yeah right as
well yeah so what is your line I guess
uh I would be mortified if I hurt
somebody out like who was not in that
kind of right there are a few chopped
Allen's Lego for something you'd be like
oh well you know at least we got the
shot we probably wouldn't get far enough
into something unless it was like a
horrific accident yeah so like when we
we did this car video recently it was
very funny yeah that's great it took me
like six months to edit that one too
um and we like you know basically cut
the frame of the car apart take the roof
off and we drove it around town and it's
like we're going 30 miles an hour hour
yeah yeah for a couple miles
it's like not a big deal yeah like
what's the worst that happens this car
just go like yeah yeah and then comes to
like a like a grinding Hall yeah right
so that I'm not too worried about and
like nothing happened anyways because
like if you cut the roof off a car and
it falls apart because of that I mean
the car was clearly not very strong yeah
that's the coast that's the gospel
like imagine
if somebody like hits the top of your
car and all of a sudden it's a
structural Integrity like Looney Tunes
off a plane if it doesn't fly well
that's the kind of the place
so who is the most the most dangerous
the most dangerous that I can think of
off the top of my head right now is this
Russian Channel called creoson
that's like a cop-out answer it's
Russian they're insane and it's amazing
or maybe they're Ukraine I don't really
know it's like an example so they go to
like Chernobyl they've gone to Chernobyl
a bunch yeah
um okay and just sort of done things
there that like like I I think I'm
pretty sure they snuck in I think they
snuck into like a Russian like the
Russian uh space shuttle facility which
is like super guarded and it's just like
this like rotting corpse of a space
shuttle yeah but like the Russian one
right and it's just on YouTube yeah it's
just on YouTube yeah and like there's
like security and stuff that they're
sneaking past and like they panic when
they like crawl up in and everything so
they're like climbing on you know
ancient scaffolding that's like not been
taken care of at all and it's like at
any point in time stuff could fall apart
some other people are like oh my god
what the [ __ ] this could go very wrong
yeah yeah I definitely play stuff up too
yeah I mean I mean you do for the
content it's good content like we bought
the X-ray machine like the first time we
made it work was actually me and Kevin
the backyard scientists so we were in my
garage we put it together hooked it all
up and then what's in the video is
essentially me kind of like going
through the process again yeah because
it's really difficult to try to film a
process like that in an entertaining way
yeah yeah so it's like I already knew
what I was doing and what looks
dangerous like it's not not dangerous
but it's also being kind of done in a
safe enough way right yeah where I'm not
like getting my hands in there I'm not
getting too close to it it's like every
time I turn that thing on I know it's on
and when I'm done I ground it like it's
being very very step by step very
procedural with like I'm not gonna put
myself damn illusion broken I can never
watch that video the same way again
but it really just is you know it's just
entertainment yeah of course yeah what's
the most dangerous thing that has
happened guys
that dog seemed very dangerous which was
on I did a thing though that one you're
helping yeah so that one is do you want
to explain the video you made it look
I'm sort of they they just strapped a
machine gun to to like a Boston Dynamic
discount yeah a discount I was kind of
disappointed wasn't the legit the
company's so mad at him oh really
I'm not surprised it's really funny
they're sending him DM's because he
tried to buy one a while ago right all
right so they're sending him DMS of like
oh we like your video could you tell us
the serial number of your robot again
they're they're like trying to shut the
robots
well it's gonna become like it's got a
taste of guns yes it can't be quenched
yeah
yeah basically yeah
dogs because nobody wants you to do this
because it's bad but the thing is like
that video I think like I'm really glad
like I I like you know I don't know I
feel like Engineers are like I like I
like the idea of all that stuff but
there's something that you need to be
able to describe to people like black
mirrorship like this is a real
possibility and you need to be like do
you want this to surprise you yeah yeah
or do you want somebody to be like
taking shortcuts to try to show you this
technology is basically possible yeah
yeah I I didn't watch that video
thinking oh wow this area responsible
putting a gun on another bike the
military is going to put a gun on a dog
yeah I mean they're putting it on the
dog regardless we want it we should just
you know we should be aware this is
gonna happen and so it's like is that
scary the military is gonna put a gun on
those dogs 100 I guaranteed send out the
dogs
who was in the set that's like uh world
war three we do not know what kind of
weapons they were they would be using
just a bunch of balls
it's like 2017. you see the hill you
like there's like a shot of like the
hills and just like okay
because the red coats are coming yeah
he's putting a gun on a dog any
different from putting bombs in a UAV
like right like that's the same thing
yeah it's just scarier because it's a
dog it's terrifying it's like that's a
thing I like I had two safeties on it so
I had two remote controls one of them
was controlling a Servo to pull the
trigger the other one literally
interrupted the power to the server so I
could disconnect the servo power it's
not even like a signal or anything it's
actually just straight up cutting power
to the servo motor yeah so if that was
disabled nothing would happen yeah right
and I had two of them and it so I had to
turn one on and then turn the other one
and then we could shoot and it's still
scary because you at some point you have
to load the thing and then walk away
from it and in that time like that's
like I don't know like that's where
things go wrong if something's gonna go
wrong that's where it's gonna go wrong
yeah they seem crazy because I remember
when I met you in L.A for the first time
you're telling me about this idea and I
was like this is insane yeah but also
sounds really interesting yeah that's
where I met you and you offered to lend
the microphone foreign
[Music]
[Music]
did people say that to you how did you
see it did you Matt we got a few funny
guys we've got some memes out there yeah
we're like we don't even know who you
are
stealing our [ __ ]
yeah do you remember like back in the
day with uh FPS Russia that's probably
that's probably like the most dangerous
like content I've seen on the most
famous clip of the truck exploding and
like the shrapnel like going right past
him the giant door oh yeah kills him yes
I mean that's that's like the worst one
but there was several times like it's
caught on camera where you can see
exploding shrapnel one of them was I
think was like a fridge door or
something oh I think I've seen that one
yeah there's a fridge door and there's
one truck nothing nothing
yeah and you can literally see his life
almost ending if he just stood a few
inches to his left to his right and I'm
just like how this is the this was the
real wild west of YouTube man holy [ __ ]
have you ever watched gun YouTube videos
back in the day yeah that was like
that was it nowadays it feels less tame
I've seen some videos of stuff and
there's this one video of the dude
getting this like I blown out from a 50
Barrett caliber or something that's
crazy
like the gun exploded like knock off
ammunition or something like that yeah
like flies back and like he's like his
dad like saves his life or something
YouTube watch see the explosion I think
you see I don't think it's super graphic
but you know it's bad he essentially
goes he does like a whole breakdown of
like what it's a really interesting
video yeah it's a good watch but like
it's still even like the stuff that they
do nowadays doesn't seem really as crazy
as like what FPS Russia was doing no
YouTube gets yeah that that man was a
YouTuber through and through because if
have you seen the interviews where
people ask him about like about did they
feel dangerous and he was like so if you
didn't know FPS Russia is an old school
YouTuber
um who it was this Russian guy who
basically just tested guns and just shot
them at things that exploded until
afterwards it came out that he wasn't
Russian at all
saying how he got that license that lets
him to buy any of the yeah crazy guns
yeah yeah wild you can do it yeah
I looked into it really yeah because I
was curious because I'm like wait a
second because machine guns are Outlaw
they're outlawed by like I think Reagan
in 1984. yeah
um and that was not a total ban on them
it just created very strict rules around
them you can still do it and there's a
couple ways of doing it and it's a whole
Nightmare and it's why nobody not many
people do it it doesn't it's I thought I
was under the impression that YouTube If
it like had gone in the title or had
guns they definitely would it would like
demonetize and demonetize it yeah I
don't I just don't do anything yeah I
mean like someone like FPS Russia aside
from what happened to him couldn't exist
in this this no no no there's no way
yeah because like I was saying like when
you when you go back to his interviews
and people ask him were you scared and
he was like well yeah me I can't
remember his real name I think it's like
Nick or something something like that
like me I was [ __ ] myself but FPS
Russia he wouldn't be scared so I
wouldn't need so
so as Russia wouldn't need safety glass
so if FPS Russia wouldn't eat safety uh
safety glass or a safety barrier then I
would I love that that's just like man
this this man was YouTube's first ever
method actor yeah yeah that's insane I
love that like that's that's insane but
yeah it's insane that he basically got
away with his life so many times
multiple times yeah doing this insane
[ __ ] on YouTube you guys watch
Mythbusters at all yeah they did really
bad [ __ ] too oh yeah like right I I
think I think they like monsters at some
point on it just completely missed the
berm and just shot into a city
what yeah
into a house someone's house yeah what
not close yeah goes far
I I do know that like the first couple
of seasons of Mythbusters was very much
like an experimental phase I think where
they were just like how much could we
get away with but then I think as the
show got bigger they were just like yeah
all right we'd probably have to be
careful because I think like in early
Seasons there was like an accident that
happened where like an explosion went
off and like Adam's eyebrow just goes
completely singed off
see like loses his entire eyebrow what
and it's like it wasn't planned it looks
like it wasn't planned he's just like
yeah I've just lost an eyebrow
they did like they blew up a cement
truck too I think that oh that one was
crazy I just I feel like it's like they
were kind of approaching stuff that you
really only see like the military do but
the military has like squads of land
that they'll just like go in the middle
of some Canyon that's like yeah why did
they blow up a cement truck
because they could I guess yeah I mean
tell me right now if you guys have the
opportunity to blow up a cement truck
you wouldn't do it
I do vividly remember that episode and
the the sound of the explosion doesn't
sound real it's it's like the type of
explosion you would only hear in like
video games because it's just so insane
it's like it's like because you just see
it it's like a tiny cement truck way off
in the distance and then a second later
it's just gone it's just smoke
and then they they walk up to and
they're like they said there was nothing
there was nothing left it's just like it
just turned to dust and I'm like and
again I don't remember why they did it
yeah
I would do it if I had the opportunity
yeah I mean that's
yeah I haven't seen that clip but I have
to watch that clip yeah that sounds
insane it's it's so entertaining yeah
but also like even there are some other
TV shows that seem like they could do
some possible dangerous dangerous stuff
I'm thinking about like old school Top
Gear as well like I wonder how much
safety precautions they did in some of
their stunts like do you remember I
can't remember if it was the Vietnam
special what it was like one of the like
Asia specials where they had to drive
across this really really narrow road I
mean you can't fake that yeah you
already fake that right but I think it's
a lot like I'm not gonna say it's less
safe than it looks but I think that it's
a lot more real than people think it is
yeah yeah yeah I think sometimes people
because you you've it's it's ad so
you're like oh they lived so it's
totally fine right so it's really easy
to do but that's I say like you know you
look at all the US rocket programs and
everything like you know I'm saying lots
of people died doing that and it's like
would you rather have your cell phone
and a couple people in the day the good
old days died yeah developing all the
technology leading up to that or we
don't ever try anything crazy like
helicopters so you think you think we
need crazy people
right now you know you you're literally
in the Mad the mad scientist
mindset yeah I mean like if I don't
strap a gun to a dog someone else
so am I as well it's like that it's like
I mean with the flying cars it's like
Society if everyone was crazy
you're being flying cars right now yeah
I definitely like I I can totally
understand
imagine like raising a kid right and
you're like oh never go outside never
touch the door handle it might be dirty
never do this yeah ah you know then
you're gonna have a weird sheltered kid
that doesn't learn any real life
experience yeah